des manifestations importantes aussi
dans la nièvre de nombreux barrages
mises en place notamment aux alentours
de nevers la circulation a été perturbée
la mobilisation avait pris de l'ampleur
au fil des jours sur les réseaux sociaux
écoutez le porte parole des gilet jaune
j'ai lancé la page avec un ami au début
pas poursuivre un petit peu le mouvement
et puis on s'est vite trouvé dépassé un
petit peu par les événements par le
nombre d'adhérents qui ont demandé à
rentrer dans le groupe on a vite passé
en deux jours les deux mille 3000
adhérents et là on est actuellement à
plus de 10000 membres
on a pu toucher vraiment beaucoup de
monde et on l'a constaté ce matin par
rapport au nombre de blocages qu'on a ce
matin on a fait le tour un petit peu en
moto justement pour se rendre compte à
travers les opérations escargot qui ont
eu lieu et les différents points de
blocage qui vont jusqu'au gong et un ou
des vraiment des petits endroits oui et
c'est là où on en est où les gens ont
fait de même un déblocage sens qu'il
sent que ça a été initiée ninite une
proposition à ce niveau là